this is the reason Speak Easy with Nick
[Applause]
Kester all right well thank you for
coming out uh we are recording in
Midtown at the blue building which is
also the home of the Psychedelic
assembly and uh we are talking tonight
with the authors of the cancelling of
the American mind how cancel culture
undermines trust destroys institutions
and threatens us all but there is a
solution I don't know about that
subtitle but we have the authors they
will explain it along with everything
else about the strange world we find
ourselves in Greg lukanov and Ricky
schlot please welcome
them
Greg as I suspect many of you know is
the uh head of fire the foundation for
individual rights and
expression and he's also the co-author
of a previous best-selling book called
The codling of the American
mind and his co-author this time is
Ricky schlot who's a New York City based
journalist who was a fellow at fire uh
researcher and has is a New York Post
columnist uh is a host of The Lost
debate uh podcast and also at times of
Reason contributor so please give it up
for Greg and
Ricky okay so let's start with the
subtitle okay the book is called the
cancelling of the American mind and then
the subtitle is cancel culture
undermines trust destroys institution
and threatens us all mdash but there is
a solution yeah okay there was some
debate about that I wanted an emoticon
in there okay I you know that might have
kept the sentence going but um why don't
we start uh Ricky what is the what's the
elevator pitch for this book what what
is it about and why is it relevant now
well I think it's twofold uh on the
first front people are still saying that
cancel culture does not exist which is
absolutely crazy and defies all
statistics uh fundamentally but also
cancel culture is not just about the
people that are torn down it's about the
epidemic crisis that it creates and the
devastation of the body of common
knowledge that we all share and um and
also the undermining of trust in between
people interpersonally and for me as a
young person the the undermining of of
being able to grow up and have the
freedom to fumble and make mistakes as
well so I think it's important on a ton
of different levels I have to say as an
old
person and you know tough you should
have been born when I was born but um
would you um Greg what is the def
working definition of cancel culture uh
it it's basically we're trying to give
it the the name of this historical era
that we're in I'm a First Amendment
lawyer I'm big on the history of freedom
of speech and a lot of what we call Mass
censorship events have names so alien
sedition 1798 um even though it's really
Sedition Act of 1798 uh redcare one 20s
Red Scare 2 also known as McCarthy as
Etc pmrc com the comic book scare so
basically we're proposing more or less
that this be a historical definition of
a unique and weird period where there's
been a lot of people losing their jobs
because of their opinion that's really
one of the things we're trying to show
is this is on par with any of these
previous moments of mass censorship and
actually exceeds them in terms of
numbers of professors fired yeah talk a
bit about the professors because I mean
there are a couple of different sites
right or locations where this is
particularly strong Academia clearly one
of them what are the numbers that you're
talking about yeah so um this was an
interesting thing we now have a great
research department at fire and that was
you know partially labor love on my part
because I was always the lawyer who was
pretending to be fire social scientist
um but we've been able to grow it that's
how we actually have our campus Free
Speech rankings which is based on 13
different factors so real quick through
the stats um so and our definition is uh
the uh the uptick of campaigns beginning
around 2014 to get people fired
deplatformed expelled um and the culture
of fear that resulted from that and I
think it's always important to root
numbers in in comparisons when I started
at fire um I started I actually landed
in Philadelphia at 9:10 a.m. on
911 all all of my first cases were
involving people who said jerky or
insensitive things about uh the attacks
or people who said let's go get those
terrorists but said it in a in a cons
considered to be rude way way um we we
now know and it was so it was a bad
period for academic freedom there was a
moral panic and it actually followed the
normal emo of mass censorship events in
history there was a national security
crisis that's usually the way it goes
it's either a national security crisis
or a large scale war that you have these
Mass censorship events um and it was bad
and everybody knew it was bad um and 17
professors were targeted um for being
canceled as we would say which basically
means like punished for their speech um
there were more students as well but
we're pretty small at the time so you
know we know that we probably know a
fraction of of the students who got in
trouble uh three professors were fired
that's really really bad historically
having um like one Professor being fired
Steven celita resulted in an entire uh
issue of the American Association of
University presidents uh University
professors to do a a whole summer issue
on it and all three of those professors
by the way were Justified under things
that weren't related to speech um W
Churchill had had pretty long history of
academic misconduct that was real the
one of the other ones Sammy aleran um
was fired because of ties real ties to
uh terrorist organizations and the third
one was fired on on the basis that she
stopped teaching her class for a
substantial chunk of time and talked
about something that wasn't related so
again bad chilled speech period I wasn't
used to professors getting fired though
particular never tenur professors in my
early career for cancel culture we're
talking about over a thousand attempts
to get professors fired or punished in
some way about two-thirds of them result
in someone um being punished in some way
about one fif of them about 200 result
in them losing their jobs um which by
the way like the number during
McCarthyism of people who lost their job
um due to being a communist is about 62
63 um they count other people who lost
their opinions in this massive study
that they did right towards the end of
mcarthism um and there were about 90
fired for their opinion over all which
is usually rounded up to 100 we now
think that they're probably somewhere
between 100 and 150 fired so 200 people
fired means it's worse like in terms of
like actual numbers what is the what's
the time period that you're 20 uh 2014
to uh to Mid uh to Mid last year to July
and the period that's considered
McCarthyism is 11 years it's it's 47 to
57 so we still we still have time but I
did want to add one more uh stat uh one
in6 we know this is a crazy undercount
as well one in six professors according
to our our survey one in six say that
they've been either threatened with
investigation or investigated for their
academic freedom that that means the
numbers are absolutely colossal students
about 9% of them say that they've been
they they've actually been faed
sanctions for their speech that's an
insanely huge number and about one-third
of professors say that they've been told
to avoid controversial research so we
know that we're just we're only seeing a
portion of it and this isn't simply what
they're doing in the classroom this is
outside of the classroom as it's three
things it's research pedagogy classroom
um and uh an extramural speech so which
means which means talking as a citizen
you you open the book and uh the book is
really well structured uh you have kind
of a a chapter that talks about a
general discussion and then you have
case studies the first case study is at
Hamlin University Ricky remind us what
happened there and why it exemplifies
cancel culture absolutely so recently
there was a case there that I think um
was unusual in the sense that it just
got widespread disdain from across the
political aisle because it was such an
egregious case of cancel culture and a
liberalism on campus but there was a
professor named Erica Lopez Prader who
um decided to show in in one of her
courses a an image of the Prophet
Muhammad which is considered
sacrilegious by some by Say by some
people who follow Islam and so she said
in her syllabus that that was going to
be on she uh in in a class she she told
people that you could get an excuse uh
from class if you if it's un untenable
for you to see that she warns them
multiple times ahead of time she gave
ample warning in every way shape and
form and also just told everyone that
the only reason I'm showing you this is
because there are some sex of Islam that
do not find this offensive this is a
piece of art that was by a Muslim uh
commissioned by a Muslim King and in the
end she ended up being squeezed out of
her job for doing that because one
student did show up to that class
decided after words that she was
offended and did a basically like a PR
uh like a press conference right
basically saying that she was she' been
so offended and AG grieved and the
president of the University came out and
said that this is beyond freedom of
speech this is just offensive and and
she ended up getting squeezed out for
that reason and it was a perfect example
of cancel culture just defying Common
Sense defying um just pluralism and
democracy in a in a very fundamental
level and so that's why we decided to
call this one out as our our first
opener because
pretty much everyone condemned it in the
end it was it was unbelievable and
Hamlin did have to reverse course and if
there's
a fired and and the University president
stepped down but more recently they
basically said that they did the right
thing in this case and and and and one
of the best articles about this is
actually omna khed who's a musl and she
said I'm offended as a Muslim but she's
offended at the idea that all a Muslim
should be offended by devotional art
because the Americans can be very
parochial sometimes my both my parents
are foreign and they they just kind
assumed oh every Muslim would be
offended by this I'm like that means you
don't know enough about what you're
talking about uh yeah I was going to say
the happy ending there is that the
University president kind of got pushed
out yeah right but what what you know
part of cancel culture is what happens
to the principles in a um you know in
some kind of controversy what was the
reaction of other academics because
that's also a big part of the book um
you know what was the professor you know
were their speech rights or their
pedagogical Freedom academic freedom
upheld or were people like no you know
what like yeah that this was a positive
case in the sense that people really
came to her defense the the idea that
she wasn't rehired in the face of it is
really stunning pen America was involved
of course fire was involved the American
Association of University pres uh
professors came out and and condemned it
so it was a moment of of some amount of
unanimity but it somehow wasn't enough
at the same time uh one of the other
places you talk about um you know canel
culture being Brit large is journalism
and the media um why don't we let's talk
about the uh case of James Bennett who
was the New York Times opinion page
editor what happened to him well the um
one I wrote an article about this
basically trying to remind people that
James Bennett you know was and part of
what they wanted him to do was help fix
the fact that in 2016 the New York Times
was like wow we're incredibly out of
touch we really didn't see Trump
happening and then you added people like
Barry Weiss to the staff you added
people like um Brett Stevens you know
both of whom they got from the Wall
Street Journal there was an attempt to
actually uh have more conservatives
involved and and also have people like
James Bennett who seemed to be you know
open to covering things from all over
the political Spectrum he he was our
editor when codling the American mind
came out at at the um at the Atlantic uh
and uh so that was kind of the setting
but but then there was you I think you
can tell the rest of the story
yeah um so so Tom Cotton who's a sitting
Senator speaking the minds of a
plurality of Americans at the time um
made made an Obed case for bringing
troops in to quell BLM riots and
protests um obviously controversial but
also a Viewpoint that is worth hearing
if it's a sitting Senator and if that's
something that a lot of Americans are
are animated to do at the time and
shared by the president of the United
States at the same time yeah no kidding
um and and as a result I mean this is
something that's frightening to both of
us as as civil Libertarians that
Prospect but as a result of just that
oped being published there was a
widespread petition at the New York
Times that a ton of their I think in the
hundreds of their employees signed
saying that they felt unsafe being there
um there were people torn down including
Bennett and also Barry Weiss at the same
point in time ended up resigning there
was an Institutional meltdown over a
Viewpoint that was widely held that
should have been tolerated and in the
end instead of of of tolerating just the
person who signed off on that oped we
had to tear him down not just the person
who even had the opinion in the first
place so I think you know there's a a
really this is a near and dear uh case
study in my heart because I'm 23 I only
recently started my career in journalism
and I think that there's a really
profound effect that this is going to
have with the next generation of young
people who might be more heterodox who
might be in the center or right leaning
like myself who say I I can't go into
the lion's den at an institution like
this where you really do want the the
the biggest and most respected newspaper
in the country to be a place where
different viewpoints can Collide do you
do you think for you and you know you're
a columnist at the New York Post you've
written widely elsewhere does it you
know just on a pure reaction level does
it make you think does it chill your
speech or does it make you kind of more
extreme and say I'm not you know Screw
The New York Times which is essentially
what Barry Weiss did right she said I
can't take this anymore and I'm going
out onto the frontier and I'm building
my own shining City on a Hill which is
the Free Press you know just how do you
think you respond to that I mean for me
personally 2014 is when we say that
cancel culture started I was 14 at the
time that's when my political
Consciousness really developed and
honestly like I had a reactionary period
of time where I saw wokeness go way
overboard or a liberalism on the left I
I Associated liberal with illiberal
which is something that I've now grown
out of and I understand the broader
context but I think that there is a a
considerable threat that the generation
of kids who come up in this censorious
age where um they feel like they can't
say what they mean or or they see um
institutional stupidity a term that that
Jonathan height coined for um just the
the culture of Conformity that happens
in these leftwing institutions you're
going to have reactionary young people
who say well I'm not that so I'm going
to go even further to the right or tack
to the opposite side which I which I
don't think is a positive thing either
yeah um Greg could you speak to you know
in Your Capacity as a lawyer like one of
the things I was striking about the
Bennett case and the book is filled with
episodes that the reader will either
remember vaguely or it's like oh you
know and then it is kind of amazing I
mean it's it's like a terrible version
of uh PR where you get this backflow of
like oh my God I had forgotten about
that or whatever but what was going on
when everybody at the New York Times who
was commenting they they kept saying I
feel unsafe unsafe unsafe is that like
HR speed is that is is that like a a
secret word that you know is the
equivalent of hitting a buzzer or
something one of the reasons why they're
saying they were unsafe is because they
had a general policy of of not
criticizing you know the the paper
unless you actually think someone made
you like unsafe so that it was actually
kind of a loophole that allowed a lot of
these reporters and employees to come
out and demand you know that that
something be be done against this
horrifying article um so it was really
kind of like they were gaming the um the
EHR system really you're right and I I
think also they were um a lot of younger
employees who went to college like
myself on the back of my ID card at NYU
it's here's 911 in the campus safety
office and a crisis hotline for your
mental health and then the bias response
hotline to report speech so if you if
you grew up you got you went to college
your administrators are saying report
those around you if you feel unsafe or
or offended on campus and then you show
up at a college and you you'd been
coddled by those administrators all the
way through then then certainly you're
going to abuse HR in the same way that
they just become your new bias response
and it's a point that we made in
coddling the American mind we call it
sort of intermediated um experiences and
I think we've made a horrible Mistake by
teaching people in a free society that
when you face a problem with someone
individually call an adult and keeping
that going for but on another level for
the whole rest of your life that is also
that makes sense doesn't it call to if
you're on a playground you know and a
bigger kid is picking on a smaller kid
yeah you know you don't expect the
little kid to go like hey you know we
really should sit down and you know work
this out right yeah I mean a lot of us
actually did that as
kids the uh we got a we got a couple of
guys who are ready to work you over in
the parking lot yeah but no but what I'm
getting at is is is that idea of the
intermediary um you know in what would
have been otherwise and I I don't know
exactly how that would apply to the New
York Times thing but is it HR HR has
become the intermediary is it uh but I'm
saying would they go after uh Tom Cotton
they would be you know I am never going
to Arkansas ever again or whatever um
but um you know is it that these were
good ideas that got out of hand or are
they bad ideas in the first place to
have that kind of intermediary
institution within a workplace there
there ideas with pluses and minuses like
like most things um but clearly we've
been sounding the alarm that they were
getting out of hand and could be abused
to to to punish speech and this is
something that fire co-founder and my
mentor Harvey silverglate was warning
way back in the 70s I'm like these
regulations are much too vague they're
going to be used to stifle speech and
meanwhile one thing that we point out in
the book you know I I definitely have a
little bit of a social science
temperament so I I like to point to
inpersonal factors and yet you went to
law school you took the easy way out I
it's true I had a ton of fun in law
school it was great
um let's talk about Psychotherapy this
was again you know you will the most
depressing remember many of these
stories and whatnot but what is going on
with therapy where uh and the way that
cancel culture has kind of worked its
way into you know if there is one
relationship where you are supposed to
be away from all of the hurly Burly of
life and be able to talk openly and
honestly with somebody it is with your
therapist what's what's going on there
well this is near and dear to my heart
because you know like my experience with
calling the American mind started with
me being hospitalized um for depression
back in the Belmont Center in
Philadelphia back in like 2007 so the
idea that you would actually have um
psychotherapists who think they should
intervene if you have wrong think um in
your mind uh when you're talking
one-on-one with them is about as
horrifying as I can imagine and it's no
exaggeration to say I'm not sure I'd
still be here if I actually had a
psychotherapist who corrected me and as
far as a chapter that we could easily
expand into its own book and maybe we
should the Psychotherapy stuff scares
the living hell out of us and I have I
know people who are actually getting
their Clinical Psychology phds I I know
we talked to a number of practitioners
um we more has come out since the since
we finished the book Barry Weiss had
some articles about you know intervening
Camille Foster talks about um ho from
the fifth column um and also a fire
board member uh he talks about going to
therapy and U he needs a lot of therapy
saying no judgment no judgment he's
working on it that's what's good he was
going to couple he was going to couple's
therapy and um he got told uh that well
maybe your problem with this
relationship is that is your
internalized racism like your
internalized like self-hatred uh
self-hatred and he's like I'm paying you
for this and and dropped out but we hear
these British fasy like talks about this
as well and in terms of like uh what
I've heard from the existing Clinical
Psychology programs is that they will
pain over the nightmare scenario of what
if it turns out the person I'm treating
is a trump
supporter or a Republican and of course
the answer is then you treat them
compassionately
not not you have to drop out you know
one of the uh you you know in the
codling of the American mind you talked
about three great untruths that you know
are governing a lot of our public
discourse and in this book you add a
fourth one could you just run through
what the three great untruths and then
what's what's the special uh cherry on
top that comes out in this I should
answer that one so the the great
untruths are these ideas that basically
um they contradict modern wisdom uh
ancient wisdom and contradict uh modern
psych psychological thinking and will
make you miserable if you believe them
so the first three are um what doesn't
kill you makes you
weaker always trust your feelings which
sounds deceptively nice but it's
terrible terrible
advice life is a battle between good
people and evil people a ter like if you
believe that truly you're going to have
a miserable life and we added a fourth
one to this one all uh no bad person has
any good
opinion to make the point that the way
we argue cancel culture is part one of
the things we try to argue is that it's
part of a dysfunctional way of arguing
that we should not tolerate
um and one of the tactics uh that we use
way too much is oh here's my argument
you did something terrible 15 years ago
I don't have to listen to you anymore
and it's like wow like that has nothing
to do with what their actual opinion was
so I always give the example of um of
Jean jaac rouso miserable human being
absolutely terrible awful to David Hume
awful to his mistress gave all his kids
up for adoption probably something in
his defense that was probably better for
the kids that was probably better for
the kids yeah that's that's a good point
but that doesn't mean he's wrong about
everything I think he's wrong about a
lot of things but I don't think he's
wrong necessarily about everything and
we understand that intuitively that just
because someone's terrible doesn't mean
they're uh they're wrong and just
because someone's great and really nice
doesn't mean they're
right um did you you know in a in a way
Ricky you are kind of coming through the
or you know coming of age in the era
that you guys are writing about did you
experience that uh you know particularly
this one where it's like well you if you
are a uh you know you're a bad person so
you have bad ideas like that's where
where did that start showing up in your
uh kind of educational experience um
well for me personally I I was in high
school in the lead up to the 2016
election and we just had a scorge of
cancel culture explode even though we
were still teenagers and I at the time
was more worried about boys and acne
than than Trump but we we we I saw that
in Mass scale um for the first time it
was really frightening to me um and
frankly as a result I self-censored for
a while and by the time I got to NYU I
knew I was in an ideological minority as
a wring libertarian here in New York
City um and I actually started hiding
books under my bed when I moved in CU I
was a a new freshman and 18 and trying
to be friends were books Thomas soul and
Jordan Peterson under the bed banished
which they're now loud and proud out on
my shelves and we just did Jordan
Peterson's podcast so cancel me now
please um but I think that it's it's the
reason that I brought up my agent our
elevator pitch is because I think it's
so important to realize that there is a
crisis of authenticity with young people
who are growing up who were supposed to
explore different ideas and be an
anarchist one day and a communist the
next day and figure it out in the end
but we've taught young people that any
of their missteps or any of their
heterodox opinions are grounds to tear
them down that's no way to grow up and
actually if you look at generation to
generation views of cancel culture uh
the older people tend to be more
negative on cancel culture and then it
goes up and up and up till you get to
Millennials who are apparently very
gung-ho but then jenzie fundamentally
switches that and actually has the most
negative view of cancel culture of any
generation and that's because you cannot
be a young person and grow up in a
graceless Society um
okay um there there is a special place
in hell and in your book for Yale law
school oh yeah um and I suspect Greg
that's because I'm betting you went to
Stanford I'm betting you didn't get into
Yale but I'm just and you and Stanford
comes in for a lot of abuse as well uh
rightly but what is going on at Yale
that is so awful well Yale is kind of
where it to a degree it started you know
the um attempt to get to cancel Nicholas
and Erica cacus back in 2015 was and I
was there actually one of videotape the
confrontation was frankly one of the
most depressing things I've seen in my
entire life um the the minority students
in particular had no better friend on
the campus than Nicholas and Eric
christakis the people are like Saints
and they're also brilliant by the way
and in 2015 um that there was what
people forget to mention is there was a
whole kind of there were about uh there
was a whole rash of sort of what would
later be called sort of black Liv matter
uh protests on campus which you know
fire as psych to defend the only problem
was a lot of them were demanding that
censorship happened that one started at
University was it Wesleyan or University
of Massachusetts that that um a paper
you know St like a student paper stopped
printing you know for example there was
a cancel attempt about someone who's
trying to be very nice at Claremont
Makenna to a student and apparently she
wasn't nice in the right way and so this
was happening all over the country and
it seemed to be kind of like there was
it only lasted for one semester and in
this case this was something related to
a Halloween message that Yale had
produced I think a like a diversity
group semi semi official saying um don't
dress up offensively for Halloween and
you know some people will argue oh but
you have to understand the context and
I'm like I understand the context for
five years Halloween had been the
biggest disaster on campus at uh what
was it like Cornell um there was a a
really creepy statement that students
find wearing uh offensive costumes may
be asked to dis robe and I was like
that's messed up so so the so we talk a
lot about some of the details of the
chakis case that that haven't been made
public before but if that was the only
case then Yale would be comparatively
fine but I looked at it and every single
year we were having some kind of crazy
case at Yale we had the case where the
student at the in the law school was
talking about um he he was a a Native
American student he sent something to
the Multicultural sociey you know uh
organizing a a party and said and said
it's going to be a total Trap House you
know which he thought meant place to you
know have fun like like drinking beer in
your but apparently the argument was
that because trap house was originally a
name for a like a drug dealer's place
that came out of black slang that that
was deeply offensive and this guy needed
to apologize to everybody and by the way
they already wrote the apology for him
um they implied that he might not be
able to be a lawyer um they basically
said said like oh but you know you have
to you have to pass this character
judgment and you know and it's like wow
like nice legal career it's a shame you
said this one thing that we don't
approve of so and and of course the
shout down that that that happened with
Kristen Wagner people really need to get
shout Downs at elite law schools are not
normal um what happened at my at
Stanford very shameful we have a whole
chapter on it um and what happened at
Yale was really was really did you just
recap very quickly what happened at this
interesting because it was a very
well-known um left-leaning
constitutional lawyer and uh Kristen
Wagner from the alliance defending
Freedom who conservative there to sort
of Kumbaya about what right and left can
agree on they were they were going to
talk about freedom of speech and I think
more than 100 students showed up you
know shouted it down had to be escorted
out it was it was a train wreck and and
I believe they had to cancel the the
event early and you know I don't think
any charges were brought against any
student but the thing that people really
need to know is that every time this
happens on a college campus whether it's
a deplatforming or Carol hoen getting
fired uh or for that matter the um the
the Nicholas caka situation universities
need to do an investigation to figure
out did the administrators do anything
to stop this and did the administrators
help put this together because when it
comes to the Carol hoen case that was
all started by a Dei administrator this
is a professor at Harvard who argued
that biological sex is real on Fox News
and ultimately Le left um due to the
backlash um the same thing even I didn't
realize this when I asked Nicholas cacus
there were a bunch of Dei administrators
in The Angry Crowd that surrounded him
and was shouting and in this case the
idea that the administrators who
actually brought the charges against the
kid who said trap house all of them
should not be at a
university um so I I think that we're
what we're what we're missing is a lot
of times people think oh you're just
blaming the students I'm like no this
it's something with students and some
administrators working together that
actually created this uh made this so
severe on campus and I I might add that
we spend a lot of time talking about
Yale and Stamford and Harvard just got
an abysmal rating and then the by far
the lowest rating on Free Speech
rankings for fire and I think that it
it's important because these are the
schools that funnel kids into the most
um influential positions in society but
they do hold disproportionate weight
because Elite colleges are inle gating
in liberalism at a rate that other
schools aren't and I think that it it
does distort our vision of young people
in the Next Generation because I I find
that people are so often shocked to hear
that jenzie doesn't like cancel culture
but that's because there are a lot of
the US like myself who are proud
dropouts or didn't go to college or
didn't go to the hoyy toyy colleges and
there are a lot of young people just
columia I am a proud Dropout um but I
think I think it's important to realize
that there there are a a whole host of
young people who did not come from this
this squeaky wheel tyranny of the
minority group of people who do show up
in institutions and scare the life out
of everyone but the fact of the matter
is whether it's young people or American
people at large uh 80% of Americans
think political correctness has gone too
far the vast majority of people do not
want to live in a world where they're
tripping over trip wires at every turn
or censoring their speech or biting
their tongue for fear that someone will
give them the worst possible
interpretation of what they said this is
a tyranny of the minority and courage is
contagious and there's strength and
numbers and I think that we really can
fight back with that knowledge
um you know just to uh St at Yale for a
minute long or too it's Yale was also
one of the birthplaces of critical legal
studies um which can you talk a bit
about where where does this cancle
culture come from sure absolutely and we
spent a fair amount of time on it
because um well we actually to be honest
we we go through it fairly quickly
because we it's a very good read I mean
there's a lot of pages but you it's it's
a good read
so the Free Speech movement began in
Berkeley in 1964 and the anti-free
speech movement began at UC Santa
Barbara in 1965 um with a person who
gets a lot of credit these days but he
really has it coming uh Herbert marcuz a
name that you've probably have many
people are familiar with this name yeah
yeah so Herbert Marcus was someone who
showed who fled Nazi Germany and showed
up and realized how bad America was um
and was considered the guru of the new
left and this um and wrote something
called repressive tolerance which you
really need to read because it's
supposed to be a great intellectual who
wrote this and it's not more complicated
than my side good people bad people no
no free speech for bad people um because
and he really I forgot that he literally
says regressive so-called conservatives
the right basically like his idea is to
have a truly free Society or Welling if
there ever was we need to actually be
intolerant of regressive voices so it's
very explicitly a call for censorship
against the right you know from and and
unfortunately there were people who
actually took him seriously and actually
agreed now for a long time what what I
describe as what I still consider myself
the the liberal leaning left actually
was winning that essentially Free Speech
was ascendant it was doing pretty well
for a while but over that over the time
and one of the things about critical
race Theory even though it's come up a
lot and fire will defend your right to
teach critical race Theory and we have
um gone to court to defend it but I do
think that every time someone mentions
that they also need to say oh and by the
way that's where speech code started
that was Herbert Mark uh that wasn't
hert Mar that that was um uh Richard
Delgado Mary matuda all basically all of
founders of critical race Theory um were
uh actually you know co-authors of the
of the words that wound book um which is
all about the hate speech movement and
this led to the speech code movement U
from the first article that came out by
Richard dogado back in 19 1980 so this
was very intentional and and like I was
saying about being into social science I
like the impersonal kind of ways of
explaining things big broad trends that
people don't have as much control over
but you have to be really clear the
anti-free speech movement was to a large
degree incredibly intentional and
continues to be yeah um to stay at Yale
as well there was something that came
out in the mid 70s called the Woodward
report can you explain what that is it
was so great yeah it was so terrific and
they specifically disavowed it in
court the Woodward report was this
wonderful report um that came out in the
1970s um and I think that was Rel I
think it was 75 yeah I don't think it
was 75 I don't know I just read your
book
yeah um the uh uh so it was it was
talking about the right to question the
unquestionable you know it was this
stirring defense of the importance of
freedom of speech even for speech that
we find deeply offensive and it was
supposed to be kind of one of the things
that really set yell apart and they're
haven't been living up to it for a long
time but one thing that was kind of
sobering to see is them actually going
to court in a case where actually there
were it was more of an attack on someone
you know uh more of attack on someone
for saying things that were uh more of
attack on the right that they they were
in a litigation against this one
professor and they specifically disowned
you know the the Woodward report
basically saying oh that's just more or
less arguing in court that that's just
puffery we didn't really mean any of
that and it was named after C van
Woodward who was a sociologist on Yale's
faculty who actually coined the term
approvingly new left yeah so he you know
just as Berkeley is no longer the home
of the Free Speech movement it's
interesting to see Yale kind of turn
completely in the opposite direction but
but I will say again Harvard really
impressed Us by coming in not just dead
last but actually getting a negative
score on the campus Free Speech ranking
so what does that mean they're stealing
people
work it's like mindes all over campus
now that essentially you get negatives
for you know deplatforming and firing
professors and we didn't actually think
that we'd get in a negative number so we
we rounded up to zero in the case of
Harvard and they came at us like with
some people being like the methodolog is
crazy and I'm like oh an opportunity to
defend our methodology largest study
ever conducted of student opinion
largest study ever conducted uh largest
database of Professor cancellations
largest database of deplatforming
largest database of speech codes and
largest database of student
cancellations ever assembled um and you
really want to take us on on this and
and now and now I think they're starting
to get it a little bit um that they that
they have a problem uh let's talk a
little bit about rightwing versions of
cancel culture which you go into the
book now you are not saying that this is
perfectly uh parallel or diametrical
right but what what is what's the
right-wing version of cancel culture
that we're seeing now rooky yeah
actually it surprises most people to to
hear that about a third of attempts to
get professors censored or fired are
coming from the right and attacks and
professors to the left of them um and
that tends to happen Less in the the
really shiny institutions that Garner
the headlines and more at smaller
schools but it's still meaningful and I
think that um it's it's it's definitely
true that the the headlines for cancel
culture have been pretty domineered uh
by by the rightwing conservative media
because there's the campus spokenness
gone crazy but it does happen in Mass on
the right right um there's Intergroup
cancel culture in a way that I think is
uh really frightening on the right we
talk about David French for example
who's maligned for having some some
different views about Trump and and
conservatism um I think especially in
the post Maga era there's a reflexive
response to anyone who might be critical
of trump or to doubt Trump to cancel
them or to squeeze them out um we talk
about Megan Kelly as an example of that
who gave me my first job in media and
was squeezed out from the right and then
from the left um in a pretty spectacular
fashion and a demonstration of how one
person who is or at the time was in
pretty much the the center right area
could be canceled by both sides um
there's also the uh divisive concept
laws that are proliferating throughout
mostly uh Republican held States or red
States what are divisive concept laws
and how do they apply to K through2 and
higher education yeah um so divisive
concept laws are ones uh uh passed in in
the state legisl across the country um
that uh by by Republican legislators
that sometimes actually try that
primarily focus on k through2 curricula
um and but also sometimes focus on books
you have in the library so on the K
through but also but most importantly
there are there was one law and I do
want to emphasize this there was one be
um and it's really bad in Florida called
the stop woke act that focused on higher
ed curricula there were some others that
focused on getting rid of Dei uh at
administrations but if you mention that
as being terrible without mentioning
that Dei administrators are often the
ones enforcing um the Orthodoxy on
campus you're missing a huge part of why
it's actually not bad for academic
freedom to to to actually reduce those
departments but when it comes to the
stop woke act it was laughably
unconstitutional we told everybody it
basically said like they actually argued
in court that under this law you could
uh have a critique of affirmative action
but you couldn't be pro- affirmative
action in in the class that's like thank
you for explaining how incredibly
unconstitutional this is and we warned
everybody that was unconstitutional they
passed it anyway they took it they um uh
we we we we took it to court we won uh
fire one one in court we got a ruling
saying that was positively dystopian and
and and and it was so so the ones the
the one that actually applies to
curricula in higher ed are laughably
unconstitutional but so far there's been
one of them and why is it different uh
like why do States have more rights to
censor things at K through 12 where it's
mandatory than at colleges where it's
voluntary well that that's the thing is
it's mandatory it's taxpayer funded and
it's your kids the idea and I and this
scares so you have this state gets to
dictate more control oh absolutely I
mean like and what I've seen that scares
the hell out of me is um some Advocates
clear clearly seem to agree with the
former governor of Virginia that we
should just let education school
graduates completely control the public
school uh system and decide what gets
taught I'm like that would be a disaster
an awful lot of what we've seen go go
wrong in higher ed including the
horrifying sort of North Korea likee
University of Delaware program those are
the products of of Education school
graduates so as long as it's mandatory
as long as it's state funded as long as
it's your your kids there should be de
Democratic oversight on that part it
gets a little more complicated when you
get to the library stuff because k312
libraries there's a there's a case on
point called Pico that talks about that
makes the point that you shouldn't be
banning a book just on the basis of its
viewpoint but of course that gets a
little complicated as well because you
can also consider things like age
appropriateness where does the rightwing
cancel culture from I'm betting Ronda
santis is not a big
marcusian but I mean where where does it
come from I mean I would say as someone
who is Right leaning and who grew up in
a context where I I realize now
wrongfully I Associated ill liberalism
with liberalism um just because of the
context of the years they grew up and
and the the world that they grew up in
going to a boarding school and then to
NYU um I I've I've realized that the
left completely left freedom of speech
which used to be a fundamental principle
of theirs up for grabs and anyone could
grab that mantle and say Here's the
restorative pluralistic Democratic
Vision to move forward but instead I
think that we've seen quite a lot of
people on the right just fight a
liberalism with a liberalism and fists
with fists in a way that is just so
infuriating because I do believe that
there are a plurality of people in the
middle who actually still want to back
to those principles that are what make
America such a a wonderful place to live
in and and potentially a place where we
could actually fix problems but instead
we're fighting fists with fists in a way
that is so disappointing to me um let's
fist to Cuff it up a little bit and why
don't people who want to ask a question
you can form a line up here um but uh
while we're waiting for people to
amazingly quickly line up in a way that
was not anticipating we'll get to you
very soon but we are now a couple of
weeks uh into a war between Israel and
uh you know Palestinians or the Hamas
government of the Gaza Strip is it and
we have seen in New York City as well as
all over the country and all over the
world some
insane uh Speech being done on college
campuses in places like Times Square by
public figures by private figures and
things like that can I ask ask you how
do you how does cancel culture fit
into this is good or bad should uh for
instance among the right uh there has
been a call to uh say anybody who is a
member of an organization that signed a
letter promoting Hamas or or you know
justifying Hamas the most famous
instance of this is a letter from
Harvard where 30 plus entirely Israel's
fault yeah that that you know they are
entirely to blame is is that
cancellation if you say anybody who is
uh one of a member of those groups
should never work again is I mean is
that a form of cancellation or is that
legitimate is it accountability culture
accountability culture um you know I've
been on TV talking about this and I
think it is still cancel culture I mean
just the fact that it's um cancel
culture that many people agree with
doesn't make it not cancel culture and I
don't like black lists I I I like to
actually deal with people individually
find out what they really think about
something you know give the benefit of
the doubt um so cancel culture is always
about now to be clear do companies have
the legal right to hire who they want
yes and and I oppose laws actually
saying that they have to hire um but I
do want people to take a deep breath
take go take some distance and say to
themselves what if we live in a country
where every company was also not just a
widget shop but also a political shop
and the boss's politics decided who get
get to keep their job and it's not that
fanciful because that's what it started
to look like in 2020 and 2021 where
people were getting fired for just
having you know mildly critical BLM uh
statements there was huge M they were
being fired for supporting BLM or being
against people for for for being mildly
critical in some cases like we we saw
huge numbers of cancell I what happened
on campus was insane in 20120 this year
like we've never been as busy as we were
uh during that so I want people to
consider what the world would look like
if essentially you have a f First
Amendment but you can't have a job if
you actually honestly say you're a
political opinion I will give one caveat
though to the Harvard students um I
think that a big part of the problem we
have as a country is that we too
reflexively hire Elite college
graduates I think this creates serious
problems and I think you should try to
find out when you're hiring from Elite
college campuses is like okay now I
understand you have a view that I find
abhorent can you work with with people
who disagree with
you and what and what I'm hearing from a
lot of employers is not only are they
not really clear if these are actually
the best and brightest you're getting
from these schools um I was about to say
anymore but they never really were um
but Le less less accurately than used to
be but they're also potentially getting
someone who will show up and demand that
you fire your you know mildly Republican
it guy because they can't they can't
stand his point of view and credit where
credits du Greg actually walks the walk
and in order to hire me to be a fellow
at fire he changed a rule that he didn't
even realize it was on the books that
required people have a college degree
and I think that it's really important
for people and employers to realize that
there are 4 million fewer college
students today than there were a decade
ago there are a lot of kids who are
actually going off that trail because
they think they can tread their own path
or because they've seen kids graduate
with degrees in feminist dance Theory
and hundreds of thousands of dollars in
debt there are very few feminist dance
Theory Majors let's be honest but um but
I think that there there are a plurality
of these young people who are genuinely
determined to pave their own path and I
give credit to employers like Greg like
IBM like Tesla like Google who are
dropping degree requirements and jobs
where that's appropriate to to broaden
out the the pool of possible applicants
to kids who did did take a different
path and didn't get mired in this a
liberalism for four years what would
happen at a place like fire if you you
know if somebody had truly abhorent
political belief
um I mean because it it seems kind of
easy to say well you know we would talk
to them individually and as long as it
didn't interfere with their work um is
that possible though um we definitely
try to maintain message discipline as an
organization um and and if someone there
was a situation that actually happened
at the ACLU uh where Chase where you
used to work work back in 99 where a
employee actually said of Abigail shri's
um reversible damage that you know uh
they get like getting rid of this book
is a hill all die on and the president
of the ACLU said well we have political
diversity at the ACLU and I was like
well I've worked there I question that
um the uh fire really does have that but
if I had someone stand up and say at at
a meeting I now support a book band just
for one book but I support book bands
it's kind of like you should find
another
job all right let's uh go through
questions quickly no preambles just a
sentence what's your question sir
Michael Myers why did F have to change
his name in order to become the ACLU and
what is happening in terms of the push
back from the fire and the ACLU in terms
of the U the blacklisting of people who
are protesting in New York City for
Palestinian rights who are who are being
blacklisted by employers what are you
doing a bridged version what happened
happened to the ACLU and what's going on
with people who are being blacklisted
for supporting Palestinian rights I've
been calling that out you know all week
I mean Alex Mor has been on TV all all
over this stuff I mean Vivic ramaswami
you know even came out and said that
Black List are wrong and I and I've I've
been I've been consistent on that um
when it comes to what happened to the
ACLU you know like ours what we say is
that there are still really good people
at the ACLU David Cole someone that I
have tremendous respect for will work
with
ACLU uh whenever you know we we agree on
a case and we have worked with
Affiliates kind of our our entire
history um when it comes to why fire
became the foundation for individual
rights um and expression instead of in
education it's partially because we
wanted to do uh do things in a way uh
that we think we wouldn't repeat some of
the mistakes because one of the things
that we thought was a mistake that the
ACLU made was having 19 practice areas
and fire is only going to do free speech
and another thing is we thought that
their defense of freedom of speech was
becoming too technical it was basically
it began and ended at at the First
Amendment um and we actually argue for a
culture of free speech something bigger
Bolder older older than that um so you
know we want to be the nation's Premier
uh Free Speech Defender and I think
we're getting there can you just very
quickly talk about how I mean you make
the argument in this book as well as in
previous work that essentially our
understanding of the first amendment is
an expression of a more robust Free
Speech culture absolutely yeah so just
kind explain that well it's kind of
weird to even have to argue about Free
Speech culture and I actually had a
debate with Ken white about this in
reason and we both don't understand each
other's point at all um the the worst
argument that I've heard against cancel
culture in my opinion is that um against
Free Speech culture is that it's an
argument that bad people make that that
essentially like Republicans utilize
this argument cynically and I'm like I'm
sorry like I can't take seriously the
idea that bad people make the argument
so I shouldn't too but we're in a we're
we're in in a common law country the
idea that there's no relationship
between culture and law doesn't make a
lick of sense and of course where do you
think the First Amendment came from was
it hand was it the uncreated Quran
handed down no it was something that a
number of people valued the idea of free
speech enough that they put it as the
first subsi of um civil liberty in in in
the Bill of Rights the other the other
two that they had were and yet it took
you know 150 or more years to get to a
point where you could kind of publish
dirty books without being arrested
there's a great book called The People's
darling privilege by Michael Kent Curtis
which I recommend to people that talks
about how back when the first amendment
meant very little legally which was
pretty much all the way up until 1925
and then beyond that a little bit um one
of the things that actually meant that
Free Speech wasn't wasn't in a complete
freef fall for at least some of that was
a culture of freedom of speech a
cultural appreciation that as we you
know say in the book everyone has a
right to their opinion right and I would
add that that one case to make that the
law on the books is not enough to
protect you is that there are three
countries with pretty robust Free Speech
protections on the books that are Russia
North Korea and turkey so you need
people to buy into too all right thank
you uh next question uh do you see a
viable
legal reform a legislative solution to
cancellation by uh payment providers
communication platforms uh other
distribution oh great question um would
you repeat it uh do you see a viable
legal uh fix to payment providers what's
web architecture um discriminate on the
basis of viewpoint while fire has a very
strong position on social media
companies that we don't like laws that
come in and tell social media companies
how they should editorialize we do get
that like if if Congress tomorrow
decided yes but when it comes to web
hosting sites when it comes to uh when
it comes to payment processors you're
not allowed to discriminate on the basis
of viewpoint you're not an expressive
Association and we know that if you
don't if if you have this you know
ability you're going you can destroy
people privately so we actually when it
comes to some of the web architecture
stuff we are sympathetic to potentially
saying you can't discriminate on the
basis of viewpoint there but we do we do
think that social media companies you
know should not be regulated in the same
way thank you next question hi in the
beginning of this interview you
mentioned that there were three periods
where you had um sort of the silence
silencing cancel culture in the past the
Red Scare one and two and the previous
one and Victorian
victorianism so where are we now in this
cycle like we're like it's it seems to
be about power the power to silence the
power to cancel the power to get someone
fired what are the forces today and how
do we know where we are in that cycle or
do you see any indication that we're
coming out of it or we're getting more
into it right so where are we in the
current cycle of censorious behavior
well I sometimes think that analogies to
the Past deceive people
um history doesn't actually repeat it
barely even Rhymes and you can learn
things from previous moments in history
but it doesn't mean that things are
going to work out the same way they
worked out before um and I think that it
takes you know people fighting back uh
in in order to actually change things so
I actually think the best parallel to
what's going on now is not the Red Scare
one or two um it's not the Sedition Act
um it's actually the Victorian era uh a
largely upper class movement that thinks
it's morally Superior that didn't
actually take place uh during a national
security crisis that actually had a sort
of puritanical idea of what should be
allowed now how did that eventually end
well for one thing it lasted a damn long
time um from 1870 to basically the end
of World War I is when it started to be
started to be afraid about there was a
great group called The Free Speech
League um that that that fought against
it um but there's no guarantee we
actually pull out of this stuff and and
it's one of the reasons why even though
we offered Solutions at the end and we
are under No Illusion that this is easy
I don't think most campuses are taking
the Free Speech problem all that
seriously I don't think they're taking
seriously the idea that they have no
Viewpoint diversity and that's actually
going to hurt their function um so I
think that we need relatively massive
changes to pull out of it and I'm not
currently seeing the political will to
do that so Ricky do you see it uh more
in generational terms you were talking
about how a lot of genz people and maybe
they're not the ones who can grab the
mic but they're like screw this like we
want to be able to talk and whatnot do
you see more as you know social progress
through a series of funerals I mean I
think with young people the the problem
is we've grown up so mired in this that
we're self-censoring in in a degree that
um I think it's something like 60%
according to fires data of students are
self-censoring and I can say in my
personal experience having gone to NYU
hiding books under my bed then deciding
one day screw this I'm writing an OBET
in the New York Post about free speech I
was terrified to do that and and the
response to it was actually tons of
people coming out of the woodwork who
I'd known who were across the the hall
for me in my dorm or classmates sitting
next to me for an entire semester
professors I'd have uh heads of
departments coming to me and they'd all
say oh I totally agree with you but just
don't tell anyone we have this
conversation and I think the problem is
young people have just been so um so
coached to think this way but also on
the in terms of whether we're we're
towards the end of this or we could get
out of this I think it's important to
remember that in this age of cancel
culture if you'd ask people I think 2016
was a big flare up Point ask people in
2018 is cancel culture over they'd be
like yeah this kind of a weird thing and
Trump happened then 2020 happened and I
think that we've realized now that in
this um in this Modern Age any sort of
social unrest that we have can really
lead us down in a liberal uh drain I
think in 2024 I predict will be um
equally as bad yeah we're pretty worried
about 2024 do you think the current
flare up over the Hamas atrocities in
Israel is that you know and and the back
and forth about that is that going to
perpetuate this or is that the type of
thing that actually pops the bubble well
here's the thing um I would like to
think that the sudden rediscovery of
freedom of speech and for the first time
really seriously talking about political
neutrality some something that we we
support at fire um is something that
makes us kind of like oh good this is
finally happening but we're not naive
this this is what always happens when
the threat is from outside of Academia
um they they circle the wagons and they
say oh academic freedom oh McCarthyism
um and and and they suddenly like they
they find the Bible again but when when
the threat comes from on campus when
it's student saying this professor is is
saying something that that the you know
the pro Palestinian students don't like
and we want to get this person fired
that's going to be the test and the test
can't just be that one test they've got
years to prove that they've actually
rediscovered freedom of speech because
if you look at the scale of sort of
cancellations that been allowed over the
last 10 years you know you've got a lot
to prove to the public so this I people
are telling me this might be an
inflection point um I will believe it
when I see it next question so piggy
backing off of the predecessor's
question you mentioned about the
Victorian area yeah and everything like
that Choose Your Own
Adventure how do we promote a culture of
humility which I know you mentioned in a
recent interview with Noom Dorman or and
or how do we promotee
intellectual diversity in our faculty at
especially at Elite institutions such
that the solutions that you'd propose
can Thrive and Greg thank you for
continuing the history and tradition of
Alan Charles K's Immaculate facial hair
and Leadership it's all about the Beards
oh man Ricky you and I are out of
luck so uh let's uh tackle that question
of ideological diversity on college
campuses is that a serious extremely
important it's it's extremely important
because groups that are uh that don't
have enough political diversity tend to
get much more radicalized in the
direction that's a group polarization
that's really wellestablished you know
social science when it comes to that
Dynamic um and we're not talking about
institutions that have a majority kind
of left leading we're talking about ones
that have super majorities and very very
small minority of of conservatives some
departments with I mean what it's like
8020 at a lot of schools where it's just
most
professors uh either Define themselves
is it usually you're using Democrat
Republican registration that's one of
the ways you can do it um and and
definitely the numbers are actually
worse than 8020 particularly
particularly in Elite colleges and I'm
just not seeing the genuine effort to
actually try to address the Viewpoint
diversity problem and I'm not sure
higher education can or necessarily
should be saved if it's not willing to
do this which is one of the reasons why
I talk about if there was was some crazy
insane test on on the humanities that
only someone like Nick Gillespie could
pass um you know one out of a million
people could pass I think that would be
a much healthier way to figure out who
the hardest working best R people are
than sending them to Harvard
today uh next question uh it seems to me
that maybe that the cancel culture might
be the latest manifestation of an innate
uh Instinct toward uh Lynch Mob
mentality
so do do you think there's anything we
can learn from past instances and are we
doomed to repeat this forever over and
over again yeah I think the um one thing
that we try to hammer home in the book
is the fact that censorship is Mankind's
natural tendency and we're all extremely
fortunate to live in the relatively tiny
sliver of History post Enlightenment
where we realize that dissenting views
are worth being heard and that free
speech is a value that we should uphold
um and I think that we we actually we
call it censorship gravity in our book
um which is the idea that like much like
you you might slouch like you need to be
like mindful to set up straight and to
to roll back your shoulders and Society
needs to do the same thing because we've
spent such a relatively tiny fraction of
human history not burning our Heretics
at the stake and unless we are very
Mindful and actually continuing this
free speech culture and embracing those
values I do agree with you that we will
slip right back into that um very
fundamental base Instinct and burning
books is terrible for the environment
right so um let's do one more question
and then we're going to
talk a little biography and wrap up Sir
all right um I uh I'm wondering if you
have a hunch about an earlier uh year
where some of this may have started uh I
graduated in 2008 and I've always been
kind of curious about the 2014 Mark I
know that's when a lot of the metrics in
colleges and that kind of thing became
noticeable but I know that even
graduating 2008 I was aware that college
seemed there seem to be a move away from
principles of free speech very much by
that point so do you have a hunches to I
like Marcus was 1965 yeah there was some
you know did something happen else to I
mean it was a slow buildup basically the
the like the liberal the pro- Free
Speech liberals to a degree had to kind
of die off and I think that actually for
a lot of my career that's one of the
reasons why campuses weren't completely
awful um they were bad when I started in
2001 campuses were worse than than I
thought and I was kind of screaming my
head off saying no the the students are
now good on freedom of speech The
Faculty is okay it's administrators that
you got to worry about because they're
actually the ones teaching people
illiberal lessons and the ones who are
bringing the charges and getting people
students expelled Etc in my first book
unlearning Liberty I talk about 2007 as
actually being the worst year that I saw
and that was the education School driven
you know University of Delaware case it
also involved a case of a student who
got you know um expelled for a collage
they they claim was threatening was
completely ridiculous case um and how
small that case that 2007 was compared
to what I would see later is is I I we
knew that something bad was coming so I
wrote a short book called freedom from
speech back in 2014 talking about how
because I I I agree with Steve Pinker
that essentially there's a lot of things
that are getting better but I think
there's a category of things that we
call problems of progress that get worse
because other things are getting better
that essentially people you know who
have more comfortable lives are going to
be less comfortable with with
disagreement with with the difficulty
and ambiguity of actually arguing across
lines of difference so um I think that
there are large societal factors that
have led to this I think that there's a
slow progression of lack of viewpoint
diversity and the left that actually was
anti-free Speech kind of taking over but
as far as the thing that sped everything
up it's social media so social media
took a number of existing Trends and
sped them up but it also created some
new ones because you couldn't really
like if you hated you hated article
Ricky wrote you'd send a new a letter to
the New York Post and it end up in in
the trash can
now with everybody talking be able to
talk at the same time you can take all
your sock puppet accounts and all your
friends and suddenly make it look like
there's a horrible movement to get rid
of this horrible racist reporter I have
and I have to do something right now
about it so cancel culture was something
one of the reasons why we think it is a
weird kind of thing that deserves to be
understood as as its own problem is it
takes ancient instincts that are pro
censorship adds a first time ever
bizarre technology that allows billions
of people to talk to each other at the
same time and uh you know it created uh
some real Madness but it also um on
balance or can you run the cost benefit
analysis on that because isn't the world
better off for social with social media
oh man okay you're drawing me into 1521
um okay so when I was uh at law school I
did six credits on censorship during the
tutor Dynasty um and uh it was my own
design because I'm a nerd um and in 1521
and then again in 1538 Henry 8 tried to
put the um Genie back in the bottle of
the printing press uh because as far as
those years are concerned this thing had
been nothing but trouble it led to the
witch trials increasing because that was
one of the best sellers initially was
the book about how to spot a witch um it
led to uh increased religious wars um it
was a terrible horrible invention that
kind of ruined the world the king um
well it as far as far as like from 1530
it it was Inc it was the original
disruptive technology now what
eventually happened with the printing
press it allowed for massive
disconfirmation which is Chip which is
getting closer to Truth by chipping away
at falsity because you had an extra
couple million people few million people
in the global discussion so ultimately
the benefits of the printing press were
huge in the short run it was kind of
disastrous and I kind of and this is the
thing I sometimes explain to height you
know or talk to him about is just the
idea that we are in an unavoidably
epistemically anarchical period we're in
a crazy period And there's no way to
just to get out of it and I think the
the early days of social media in so
many ways like we're still trying to get
our footing and figure out the the
basics here um both in terms of how do
we engage in dialogue online and and not
tear each other down but not censor
people who are criticizing verser usly
but also on the on the front of of young
people and social media and Technology I
mean even despite the fact that that's a
very near and dear issue to my heart um
having grown up with social media having
a ton of friends with with scars on
their wrists as a result of being on
Tumblr for their entire tween years like
we're still we're still trying to find
the groundwork and the footing and
despite that context and the fact that I
I I saw secondhand some of the the worst
steps of what social media can do I am
still a techno Optimist I do think that
we'll figure out as a culture when is it
appropriate for kids to go online when
is it uh what are the the confines of
speech that that is appropriate in a
social media uh world but we're in that
crazy space where we just don't have any
idea what the ground rules are and I
really do hold out the possibility that
those extra billion on individual
problems can if we harnessed it better
and didn't waste our time on cat videos
and cancel culture could actually be
something that could help us figure out
me at cat videos I do love cat videos
yeah they're very uh soothing um and
they are the they are the way forward I
mean I think we all agree um you know it
is interesting to think about it being
in the early stages of social media
because we and especially if you um
think about it the broader term
participatory culture which really
started cranking up in the 90s people
are like oh no this is never going to
change we're never going to learn
anything but you know Greg you were
citing uh the problems that Henry VII
had with the printing press a century
later there was another Mass profusion
under King Charles you know starting
under King James in England and you know
there was a period where tens of
thousands of pamphlets were being
published on a on an annual basis and
it's kind of Glorious when you look back
because it gave voice to a lot of people
ugly um let's close out by talking a
little bit about these steps of how do
we get to that place where we're doing
better um one of your in the part three
of the book you talk about what to do
about it uh one is raising kids who are
not
counsellors I always get scared whenever
I hear that the children are our future
having been one and having given you
know having fathered too but um how do
we raise kids who are not counselors
well I think that the most important
thing that gives parents a leg up right
now is realizing that most young people
actually know whether or not they
understand Free Speech Basics they
understand that they don't want to live
in a graceless cancel culture Society so
there are a couple things that that
parents can do one is lead by example
and actually be mindful of the fact that
for example for me I was never offered a
debate Club at school I was taught
pretty um implicitly that that words can
wound and that uh differing viewpoints
can be dangerous uh and parents need to
take care to counteract that and not
just take for granted that their kids
schools are inculcating those values
it's you should be playing Devil's
Advocate at the kitchen table you should
also teach people I think this is the
most important thing that kids need to
realize is that there's strength and
numbers and that if their friend gets
torn down if they're a good person it
doesn't matter if if they agree with the
speech that they're getting attacked for
but they need to stand up for their
friends because every single person
today that is getting a new job getting
their first job I had an iPhone when I
was 10 we all have stupid bad stuff in
our past because we been overly online
and our digital footprint is massive but
we need to all realize that we need to
have a ceasefire and until we do that
young people need to be willing to stand
up for their friends and to say they're
a good person and you're attacking them
and maligning them in in an unfair way
uh Greg one of the other uh chapters
that you talk about is keeping your
corporation out of the culture War so
any CEOs in the audience please perk up
what what does that mean to keep your
corporation out of the culture War well
part one is try to make sure you're not
hand handing counselors uh hiring
counselors in the first place make sure
that you actually have something in the
screening saying again can you work with
people you disagree with and you know I
think most employees will say sure and
it's like really like and then ask them
kind of like what if what if a fellow
employe it is interesting like if
somebody says no I can't then you you
know okay next you should name
particular issues you know like like
saying kind of like what what if I think
I'm totally on Israel side on this or
what if I think biological sex is real
you actually we do this at fire we
actually give them like real examples of
like can you defend this speech because
if the answer
is we're not hiring you um so I think
that the screening process is a big part
of it I actually think that uni that a
lot of corporations are going to find
out just like universities the
tremendous benefit of political
neutrality of not taking a freaking
position on everything going on in the
world you talk about coinbase uh the
crypto exchange um explain what they did
their CEO Brian Armstrong at one point
in time just drew a A Line in the Sand
and said we as an institution our
viewpoint neutal control you're
perfectly welcome to have your own
politics and your own time but we're not
going to make any stances as as a
corporation and they said you can either
take it or leave it and around 5% of
their employees left it and actually
packed up as a result and those are the
5% of people that you just don't want
working for you so more power to I mean
that is kind of an elegant solution they
got to pay out to go away and they're
better off and then the the you know
it's a Winn win win win um what about in
a uh you know universities uh to bring
it back to you know the current
situation um in Israel uh universities
love to shoot their mouths off about all
kinds of things should universities you
know Greg and your perfect Universe
would universities never talk about
anything other than higher education or
should they be you know is the problem
that they're making too many statements
or that they are not making the right
statements or that they're just
hypocritical in in my perfect Universe
um every University would adopt a a 1967
University of Chicago Calvin report
which is a very strong admonition not to
take political positions like we we are
not the speaker We Are The Forum for the
speakers and the thinkers which I think
is the right attitude to have about
higher education however the fact that
they decided to do this now when they've
talked about every other issue ever is
something I'm also I have something in
the OC Register talking about like how
cynical like you should be cynical you
should be skeptical they're discovering
this you know partially for cynical
reasons because they're two and and by
the way you know what this comes from
this comes from cancel culture because
like what happened at Harvard the way
you're able to have students who think
think everyone's going to think my
position that uh that Israel is entirely
responsible for these horrific attacks
is you know it's a pretty commonly held
opinion and that people are probably
going to disagree with me and that's and
that's that's normal is partially
because people were too afraid to
actually say no that's nuts so cancel
culture partially created that but the
other way that it created it was I know
that a lot of these University
presidents support Israel I know that
they actually thought the homas attacks
were absolutely horrifying and they were
too afraid to say so because they
thought their careers might be are they
afraid of because there's no question
that you know
Americans uh broadly speaking you know I
mean a massive majorities as well as
people in universities would be of
course these are horrific barbaric
attacks they're they're afraid of three
things their faculty their
administrators and their students not
all of them but the most activist ones
are the ones they're afraid
of um the finally uh and I'm not
exhausting the entire part three what to
do about it but you uh talk about the
adulthood of the American mind explain
what you mean by that Ricky yeah so this
is the the conclusion of our our book
where we really make the case that we
all need to buy into this free speech
culture that the only way we can
supplant cancel culture is by going back
to the old idioms that so many Americans
were raised up with like to each their
own this is a free country Everyone's
entitled to their own opinion because I
think we've underestimated just how far
we drifted away from that parents have
not realized that they need to be
aggressively mindful in instilling those
values into a generation of young people
who've been taught the absolute opposite
whether it was in K to2 or in college
campuses that words can wound and always
trust your feelings and that you can
insulate yourself you need safe spaces
and Trigger warnings we all need to buy
in to fight back against this tyranny of
the minority of people who want to tear
other people down to exercise cheap ad
homenum attacks and Dodge actual
meaningful conversation because that's
the only way if we actually want to move
forward in a diverse and pluralistic
society we need to be able to have civil
conversation and dialogue about the
touchiest and most contentious issues
and unless we actually mindfully fight
back against cancel culture we are just
going to slump down into dangerous and
illiberal tendencies all right thank you
we're going to leave it there we
have this has been the Reon Speak Easy
which is a live taping of the reason
interview podcast we've been talking
with Greg lukanov and Ricky schlot
authors of the cancelling of the
American mind ccel culture undermines
trust destroys institutions and
threatens us all but there is a solution
please give them a big big round of
applause
oh